there was a young man from Wisconsin who
was blessed with an enormous a large
Johnson now this is high class brother
Netflix's the crown is back with another
season giving us one more look into the
private lives of the royal family and
season three marks eight changing of the
guard
not just in the nearly complete recast
of the show but in the marking of a new
era in England
this isn't your crown season one or two
Winston Churchill has died a new Prime
Minister has been elected and the
Queen's getting herself a nice new stamp
a great many changes but there we are
age is rarely kind to anyone what a wild
life she leads but this all is laid out
to tell you things are changing as we
now dive into pockets of English history
from 1964 until 1977 and luckily thinks
story majored in English history so I
can explain it all and yeah that's a
complete lie but I'll try anyways I'll
also be going into theories on what the
crown might be covering for season four
as a lot has been set up for us at the
end of the season but to get there we
must start from the beginning where its
new queen who dis Olivia Colman because
apparently on this show winning an Emmy
for playing a queen isn't good enough
you have to win an Oscar for playing one
so please drop at Bracken and all of
your favorite characters are back just
older Philip Duke of Edinburgh once
played by Doctor Who's Matt Smith is now
being played by tobias menzies
Princess Margaret who is portrayed by
Vanessa Kirby is now portrayed by
Bellatrix Lestrange her husband Anthony
Earl of Snowdon is no longer Ozymandias
but Ben Daniels who you might know from
house of cards or Law & Order UK yes it
seems like just about everyone has been
recast except for Winston Churchill who
immediately dies but it's through these
new eyes we shall experience the
intricacies of life behind the crown for
the next 13 years a story not so easily
told as well the life of a monarch is so
far removed from the average life of
yours or mine I mean the closest I get
to royalty is Burger King to get us to
bind two characters from the world that
all at once strange privileged high
stakes low temperament selfish and
selfish truly is the show's crowning
achievement but while every day England
moves and changes Queen Elizabeth and
the monarchy remain a solid constant
over season 3 the Queen struggles with a
Russian spy within her inner circle who
for a brief while she believes to be the
Prime Minister a quite timely storyline
considering the state of u.s. politics
today a bailout crisis hinging in the
performance of her younger
individualistic sister Princess Margaret
a national tragedy from a catastrophic
collapse of a collieries spoil tip an
attempted coup and worst of all
documentary filmmaking in the palace but
the focus swiftly seems to shift to one
character Prince Charles and his story
is not only incredibly relevant to the
events of the monarchy in the 70s but
they're gonna be center stage come next
season it all starts with Wales and
episode 6 titled target assault come out
clear as you could Kubu which if you
speak Welsh and were able to get past my
horrid pronunciation you had no means
Prince of Wales at this time in the UK
the party of Wales a political party
pushing for separation from the UK had
gained its first seat in parliament and
was building momentum English Welsh
relations were shaky all while it was
time for Charles to make his official
debut now every future King is granted
the title Prince of Wales it's just a
thing that happens like an old diner
waitress calling you sweetie
so Charles is sent to a Welsh school to
learn some Welsh so he can speak Welsh
in his Prince of Wales speech so perhaps
the people of Wales might get a little
less angry at the English but it's here
at this point where the root of
individualism in Charles takes place the
prince meets with his tutor
Edward Millward who is an
unapologetically political and
opinionated Welsh nationalist and here
Charles learns the history of the Welsh
people in an effort to show
understanding he then makes some
personal changes to his speech on
respecting the Welsh identity which when
the Queen finds out she's pretty peeved
a monarch does not take a position they
are impartial people will always want us
to smile or agree or frown or speak
and the minute that we do we will have
declared a position but it matters not
as the instinct to do what his personal
emotional individual has emerged in
Charles the perfect setup for a
scandalous romance that's to last
decades you see Charles has started
seeing Camilla Camilla used to be with a
chap named Andrew Parker Bowles but they
broke it off because Andrew Parker
Bowles was hooking up with Charles's
sister Princess Anne your typical royal
love triangle when Charles invites
Camilla over for her average
run-of-the-mill first date in a palace
he becomes smitten and we learned that
Charles has been writing the duke of
windsor remember this guy the one who
gave up the crown and hung out with
Hitler will he spit blood into a toilet
and now he's on the way out as part of
his reconciliation with the Queen before
he croaks he shows Elisabeth the letters
of correspondence between him and the
prince where Charles speaks so highly of
his great-uncle as Charles begins to
experience real love he empathizes with
the Duke and starts to see similarities
between them he too was once Prince of
Wales heir to the throne he too is
feeling stymied and choked by his duty
to be an impartial emotionless royal he
sees the royal family as the ones who
cruelly united against his great uncle
and now he's to receive the same fate
Uwe cruelly denied your right to reign
alongside the woman that you wanted by
your side and that individualistic
instinct that was planted in Wales grows
stronger Charles doesn't want to lose
Camilla as Andrew Parker Bowles is still
interested in her so he makes a plea to
Tywin Lannister I mean Earl Mountbatten
to help the family come around to
Camilla being a serious match for him
but this was decades before Game of
Thrones ever aired so Charles wasn't
aware that you never trust Tywin
Lannister he and the Queen Mother meet
and plot to end the romance as Camilla
is not a suitable match Charles is sent
on an 8-month posting in the Navy which
he confronts the Queen about though
Elizabeth doesn't know anything about it
she does suspect the Queen Mother and
Montanan are behind this the two then
have the Queen sit down with Princess
Anne who reveals the love triangle when
they tell Anne that Charles likely plans
to marry Camilla and says fine as
he's prepared for that to always be
three in the marriage the third being
Andrew Parker Bowles who is still
sleeping with Camilla during her romance
with Charles I'll also add as a side
note that Princess Diana upon her
divorce from Charles due to his
infidelity with Camilla famously stated
well there was three of us in this
marriage so I was a bit crowded Anne's
line stating the same thing feels like a
cheeky little easter egg edition by the
writers so an arrangement is put in
place by the Queen mother to have
Camilla and the Parker Bowles boy be
married and since Camilla is indeed in
love with him she willingly agrees the
two are married and Charles is
devastated now you might be saying
alright that's all well and good but
what's the point what's with all the
focus on Charles
everything here is setting up for what
will be a major aspect of season four
Charles's love affair with Camilla and
of course the introduction of Princess
Diana a highly scandalous time for the
monarchy and something that will
certainly vex the Queen as the show puts
it at the end of the season when
Princess Margaret's marriage has fallen
apart the monarchy papers over the
cracks what we do is loud the monarchy
is meant to display strength and provide
confidence when all around things are
falling apart
but how can a monarch do that when they
retreat into the individualistic these
selfs the emotional the positional the
path forward Charles is taking so let's
talk what's next for the crown what are
some of the events we can expect from
season four first off there won't be any
major casting changes like what we saw
between seasons two and three filming of
the season has already started and no
major roles will be changed rules will
only be added apart from what the show
has already set up with Charles and
Camilla we certainly know we will be
seeing Princess Diana as this is one of
those roles added to the show that's
been publicly announced undoubtedly a
major aspect of the show will become
Charles and Diana's marriage Charles's
infidelity with Camilla and the trouble
the two faced in their marriage as well
as the scandal that fell upon the
monarchy we also know that the timeline
will go well into the 80s as this photo
taken from the season four set shows
Charles and Diana
trip to Australia in 1983 two years
after they marry but don't expect much
or any of 90s Diana as show writer Peter
Morgan told The Hollywood Reporter in a
2017 interview that each season will
only span a decade so in all likelihood
it won't be until season five that we
see the tragedy of Diana and season four
will remain totally 80s of course that
also means the introduction of Margaret
Thatcher into the series to be played by
Gillian Anderson of x-file fame as
Thatcher was prime minister from 1979 to
1990 and if the Iron Lady is set to make
an entrance into the series it is also
likely that this show will highlight
Margaret Thatcher's exposing of the
Anthony Blunt spy scandal in the very
first episode of this season is revealed
that royal art adviser Anthony Blunt was
actually a KGB spy to save the country
from shame and to prevent Allied nations
from losing trust in England blunt was
given immunity from persecution and the
whole thing was kept quiet in 1979
however Margaret Thatcher publicly
reveals this information given that this
was the center point of episode 1 I
imagine that church outing of this
information will be a point referenced
in season 4 as for some of our other
members of the royal family Helena
Bonham Carter said in an interview with
town country that Margaret surgery to
have part of her lung removed will be
touched upon in season 4 we can also be
certain the infamous Michael Fagan
intrusion will be included in the show
as the character has already been cast
Michael Fagan famously broke into the
Queen's bedroom in 1982 in what was
considered one of the most severe royal
security breaches of the twentieth
century so overall this season of the
crown was fascinating to watch held by
an incredibly strong performance from
Olivia Colman not an easy thing to do
when you're taking over from an equally
strong Claire Foy each episode gave us a
fascinating look at the Enigma that is
the private lives of the royal family
and I really enjoyed watching it so if
you enjoyed the season and this video I
hope you'll annoy me with a like and a
sub and leave your comments thoughts and
theories for season or in the comments
below be sure to follow me on Twitter at
think story whitey and remember God
saved the Queen I mean daddy loves you
very much